Now we have looked at strategy selection a little bit, let us look at
strategy integration. Even if the agent selects a particular strategy,
it is not necessarily stuck with that strategy. As the problem-solving evolves,
it may well decide to shift from one strategy to another strategy.
As an example, consider that for a given problem,
metacognition decides to select the strategy of case-based reasoning.
Now case-based reasoning spawns a number of sub-tasks. Retrieval, adaptation,
evaluation, and storage. Metacognition can now examine the requirements for
each of the sub-tasks. And then, with each of the sub-tasks,
it may decide on some strategy. For example, for the task of adaptation,
metacognition may pick the method of case-based reasoning recursively. Or
it may pick the method of rules to adapt a case. Or it may use models for
the case adaptation. If metacognition picks the method of rule based reasoning,
then note that metacognition has shifted from the method of
case-based reasoning overall to the method of rule-based reasoning. For
a sub-task of case-based reasoning. We can also use a similar analysis at
the next lower level. Suppose that metacognition decides to pick the method of
rule-based reasoning for doing the case adaptation. Now the question becomes,
what rule to apply. Rule 1, 2, or 3. We can imagine meta-rules that select,
which rule to apply in any given condition.
We've come across a use of metacognition for strategy integration earlier.
And this blocks microworld, we saw how means [INAUDIBLE] can reach a cul-de-sac.
When the cul-de-sac happens, metacognition may, set up a new reasoning goal and
select a strategy of problem reduction for resolving the cul-de-sac. Problem
reduction then, sets up four independent goals. We made it work back to mean
internal assist to achieve each goal independently. In this particular case,
we have integrated means and internal assistance and problem reduction and
the reasoning has shifted between these two strategies in a seamless way.